Kevin DLC ont disparu dans la nuit du 25
au 26 novembre
ils étaient dans un petit village à
prabesques ils ont
disparu la dernière fois qu'on a de leur
nouvelle c'est à 3h du matin
et là récemment après de nombreuses
recherches récemment la gendarmerie à
avancer à grands pas non je vous jure
c'est pas moi là vraiment je vous
promets que c'est pas moi dégage
donc je disais que la gendarmerie avait
fait un grand pas en avant puisqu'on a à
l'heure actuelle 3 suspects un premier
qui a été déféré qui est actuellement
chez le juge d'instruction probablement
pour être mis en examen et pour
peut-être incarcéré
un deuxième est encore en garde à vue et
un troisième vient d'être arrêté
j'ai eu l'info au moment où je venais me
rendre sur votre plateau alors on va
remonter donc à la nuit du 25 au 26
novembre
ce jour là Leslie et Kevin alors ils
sont jeunes ils ont 22 et 21 ans
débutant ils sont ensemble oui ils
habitent ensemble et ils sont logés chez
un garçon qui s'appelle Tom
et
Leslie et auto-entrepreneuse dans le
bâtiment
Kevin
contemple la vie
sans faire grand-chose
les recherches
enfin l'enquête c'est pendant pendant
tous ces mois qui viennent de s'écouler
l'enquête l'enquête avant 7 en
discrètement
un certain nombre de proches notamment
Tom chez qui ils vivaient a été
longuement entendu on lui a demandé où
il était ce qu'il a fait cette nuit là
il a donné des explications il a donné
des endroits il a dit qu'il était sur
une dans une rêve partie
et en coup de soleil il était pas dans
ce village de pradec
le 8 décembre donc peu de temps après la
disparition on retrouve dans un
container dans un petit village qui
s'appelle puravo on retrouve des effets
personnels de Leslie et Kevin et
notamment des pièces le BCR c'est pour
avoir l'autorisation de conduire un
scooter au nombre Kevin et on retrouve
quatre cartouches de fusil de chasse non
percuté donc en ordre de marche
à ce moment-là les gendarmes gardent ça
comprennent pas ce que ses affaires font
là une trentaine de kilomètres de là et
puis il vérifie les explications
fournies par Tom pendant sa première
audition où il dit qu'il était à la race
party etc etc et on s'aperçoit que par
rapport à ce téléphone il ça colle pas
du tout ça colle pas
du coup il c'est la dernière personne
qui a été
appelée
les téléphones ça va pas du tout alors
il y a bien pire parce que j'ai on a un
envoyé spécial sur place du journal qui
est Vincent Senecal qui que j'ai eu au
téléphone longuement qui m'a qui m'a
donné les derniers éléments de son
enquête
les gendarmes ont bénéficié d'un d'un
coup de pouce par dans le milieu de la
des dealers il y a un mec qui balance
Tom d'accord mec balance Tom et il
balance des choses très intéressantes il
y a trois points le premier point c'est
que Tom se renseignait pour essayer de
trouver un endroit tranquille une plante
dans le marais poitevin d'accord c'est
déjà ensuite il cherchait à se procurer
il faut que je retrouve sur mes fiches
le nom exact
des hallucinations des vomissements
vomissements dont avait été victime la
jeune femme elle s'en va
le dont il cherche à se fournir du à se
procurer du datura qui effectivement
provoque des vomissements
et enfin il cherchait à savoir comment
on pouvait faire démarrer une voiture
sans avoir les clés d'accord bon ça
commence justement
dans cette histoire c'est que Tom le
garçon dont vous parlait il était
présent au battu pour rechercher les
deux disparitions il y a des battus qui
ont été faites et il a même parlé aux
journalistes d'ailleurs tout à fait
il ne comprend toujours pas comment ses
amis ont pu se volatiliser mais ils
avaient toujours les clés de chez moi
ils vivaient chez moi oui j'étais plus
chez moi depuis un mois et demi j'ai
voulu en camion aménagé puis voilà quoi
plus de nouvelles pour avoir les réseaux
puis de nouvelles de personnes quoi donc
au bout d'un moment comment ça
s'inquiéter on ne parle pas de famille
bah c'est quand même
et ce qui est encore plus intéressant
c'est que le train de vie de ce garçon
semble avoir complètement changé
quelques jours après la disparition de
Leslie Kelly alors il a rien acheté mais
en tout cas il avait 15 fioles des
Olivettes de cocaïne conditionnée à 6 g
donc 15 je connais pas le tarif exact
mais en face ça fait quand même beaucoup
d'argent
et je précise que Kevin au moment où il
disparaît avait 10000 euros en liquide
sur lui
donc
je pense qu'on a un premier temps il a
acheté des produits et qu'on a un
deuxième temps il a été il s'est fait
dépouillé de ses produits voilà et voilà
donc
quels sont les donc l'épicières la piste
de Tom il y a deux autres personnes vous
avez dit qu'ils ont été appréhendés
quelle est la vers quoi on se dirige
parce que si on en parle aussi ce soir
c'est que forcément la famille et nous
on a encore un espoir de les retrouver
et c'est vrai que TPMP voilà il y a
beaucoup de gens qui regardent etc si
vous avez des infos si vous avez
peut-être vu quelque chose si vous avez
entendu parler de cette histoire si vous
avez peut-être revu
Leslie et Kevin n'hésitez pas voilà à
contacter peut-être nouveau détective ou
à contacter la police ou à contacter
voilà les gens parce que c'est vrai que
cette histoire est incroyable et les
parents on a vu ce qu'on dit les parents
les parents ils ont dit et pas on dit
impossible que ce soit une fugue pour
eux il y a zéro chance
alors c'est quoi cette histoire du chien
l'histoire du chien c'est un pitbull en
fait c'est un stuff mais non mélangé
avec un malinois d'accord qui a pas qui
appartenait à Leslie qui était le chien
deslie et pendant qu'elle était
sa blanquette partie c'est une soirée à
20 mètres de la de la maison de Tom le
chien était resté dans la maison de Tom
et le chien n'y est plus donc quand ils
sont partis à 3h du matin ils sont
forcément allés chercher le chien pour
aller je ne sais où et rencontrer
probablement les gens qui les ont
agressés et puis après il y a le mobile
parce que
soit c'est un une histoire de au milieu
de dealer de stupéfiant possible
soit c'est une histoire de rivalité
amoureuse parce qu'il semble quand même
que Tom ait eu le béguin comme on dit
pour
pour Leslie certains disent qu'ils
auraient une histoire d'autres disent
que c'est resté au stade de la
frustration et il était d'autant plus
frustré que c'est lui qui avait présenté
Leslie à Kevin mais pas du tout dans le
but donc a priori Tom au départ était
amoureux de Leslie il l'a présente à
Kévin Kevin et s'ils se mettent en
couple et lui au départ il a pas du tout
présenté Leslie à Kevin dans le but qui
se mettait ensemble alors c'était pas du
tout son but voilà donc Kevin habitait
avec Tom donc le mobile voilà c'est vrai
ça ça peut être un mélange de tout ça
aussi parce que les deux étaient quand
même aussi impliqués dans un trafic de
stup il était dealers tous les deux
Kevin et Tom
et puis il y a cette histoire de
rivalité amoureuse donc on a peut-être
avec tout ça le les explications mais
c'est une fois plus un peu tôt
peuvent disparaître totalement comme ça
en 2023 il y a pas une caméra il y a
personne qui a rien vu il y a rien rien
on est en pleine campagne
alors parce que le profil de Tom c'est
un jeune homme de 22 ans c'est un
installateur de cuisine industrielle il
est au chômage son emploi il ditrait
régulièrement des drogues cocaïne
kétamines particulièrement en teuf et
donc comme vous l'avez dit le soir de
leur disparition Leslie Kevin devait
dormir chez lui mais ce qu'il faut
savoir ce que vous avez dit donc c'est
que Kévin et Tom eux étaient
colocataires c'est ça oui
la maison où il dormait c'est Tom
l'avait en location
et il hébergeait Kevin un jour il reçoit
il reçoit les Sicks parce qu'il est il
était copain avec Leslie tom était
copains avec Leslie d'accord et comme il
hébergeait Kevin c'est comme ça qu'ils
sont rencontrés c'est ça puisque c'est
lui qui connaissait Leslie en premier
juste les deux les deux autres personnes
qui ont été entendues par la police
c'est ce qui c'est qui alors c'est très
peu de choses là-dessus parce que ça
c'est très récent l'interpellation de
Tom c'est mardi
la garde à vue de Tom amène les
gendarmes à rechercher le numéro 2 qui
s'appelait qui serait l'homme Nathan
d'accord il était à l'île de sur l'île
de Ré il a été interpellé sur l'île de
réaler lui aussi on est pas sûr d'accord
je dans le doute je préfère dire que non
j'en sais rien quant au troisième j'ai
aucune information il est la garde à vue
a commencé tout à l'heure d'accord donc
on est très rapide sur le sur l'info et
pour confirmer un petit peu tout ça là
on était sur le datura le datura
effectivement c'est une plante
hallucinogène qui a tendance à faire
vomir or il se trouve et on sait qu'à 3h
à 2h53 du matin Leslie a envoyé un SMS à
Tom en lui disant qu'elle était malade
qu'elle avait vomi qu'elle vomissait du
sang et j'ajoute qu'à minuit
kevin est sorti de ce fameux dîner
blanquette party chez un chez les
copains certains Nicolas et quand il est
revenu il était blême il transpirait il
était blanc comme un linge
on sait que Tom a bu l'apéro à partir de
18h avec Leslie et Kevin d'ici à penser
que il aurait absorbé de ce de ce
produit il y a pas des kilomètres alors
c'est une histoire on va avoir des
éléments parce que l'enquête avance
plus en plus
on a l'impression que les to se resserre
clairement
à partir du moment où il déclenche les
garde à vue si vous voulez c'est qu'ils
ont ils sont chargés ils ont des ils ont
des éléments donc là une première fois
qu'on voit comme ça
une personne qui alors c'est pas du tout
peut-être que Tom est complètement
innocent mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
parfois des gens aussi qui qui parlent à
la caméra comme ça on a vu l'affaire
les auteurs se sont répandus c'est
vraiment dans les médias qui disaient
oui on les connaît bien en tout cas on
sait pas pour l'instant on sait pas sur
cette histoire mais ce serait ce serait
encore étonnant merci Michel vous nous
donnez des infos bien sûr sur cette
affaire et que vous en avez et puis
surtout nous on a voilà on a envie de
garder espoir pour la famille surtout
pour la famille et pour les proches de
Leslie et Kevin et si vous avez entendu
quelque chose si vous voulez vous savez
peut-être vu si vous avez des éléments
appelés tout de suite la police voilà
pour que on en sache un peu plus
peut-être que si vous entend ez cette
histoire soit peut-être ça va vous dire
quelque chose et vous dire ah oui j'ai
peut-être vu quelque chose m'ont entendu
quelque chose qui fait que je pourrais
faire avancer l'enquête encore plus vite
et peut-être essayer de le retrouver
Kevin et Leslie